From the star of Rocky, Rambo, and The Italian Stallion
Comes the only 80's action movie to come out
in 2010:
The Expendables.
Before the release of the watered-down PG-13
sequel
revisit the R-rated movie that has all the
explosions, guns, and testosterone you crave
And all the plotty overcomplicated backstory
you don't.
"Remember that time we was up in Bosnia? We
took down them Serb bad boys while our guys
were getting chopped up all around us --"
No one cares! Just shoot a bunch of people
already!
Ahh, that's better.
Meet The Expendables, a mercenary gang of
aging movie stars brought together for one
last paycheck.
Thrill as the heroes of your youth team up,
without nearly enough screen-time to go around,
Featuring hours worth of Statham and Stallone
But only 2 minutes of Willis and Schwarzenegger.
He... won't be back.
Instead of the all-star brawl you were promised
on the poster,
Get ready for showdowns that no one ever asked
for, like
Jet Li versus Dolf Lundgren,
Steve Austin versus Randy Couture,
And Jason Statham versus a pickup basketball
team.
"Next time I'll deflate all your balls."
Suit up with the leader of The Expendables:
Barney Ross, a man with a mysterious past,
and a mysterious color-changing goatee.
Watch this killer with a conscience struggle
through tough choices to do the right thing.
"This is my choice. There's no guilt.
No guilt."
And struggle through Botox to make his face
smile.
Ahh, almost there! Almost got it!
Aw.
Ride along on his mission to take down this
generically evil CIA agent
And this generically evil general
To save this generically Latin island nation
going through some kind of coup or revolution
or something.
"They wanted me out. Why? Because I saw the
big picture!"
Once again: no one cares!
But it's not just boys playing with their
toys.
Get to know the movie's rich female characters
like
This helpless hostage,
This cheating girlfriend,
This random biker skank.
"Anything for you, baby."
And.. uhh.. that's all, I guess.
Not a lot of women in this movie.
Gear up for a film that seamlessly blends
the worst action movie cliches of the last
forty years,
Featuring:
Heroes who somehow dodge every bullet from
the 80's,
Corny one liners from the 90's,
Lame CGI blood effects from the 2000's,
And lame CGI everything else from today.
So get ready to say "Huh?" in a movie
full of Asian, Latin, and European actors
who speak English as a second language.
And also Sylvester Stallone.
Is that English?
Starring...
Sylvester Staroids
Cranky
Ivan Drunko
The Buh Buh Buh Buh Buh Black Guy
Lucky To Be Here
Bruce Will-isn't In The Movie
Plane Li
Greasy Gandalf
and Old Man The Barbarian
The Expendables
Man all I really wanted to see is these guys
trade one liners.
"I'll be back!"
"You've been back enough! I'LL be back."
"Yippee ki yay."
Nevermind.